- Welcome back everyone
to new Coffee Break here
on my channel Firm Learning.
As you know, I am Heinrich
and on my channel I try
to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And today I'm very excited
about this episode because it is going to
be an episode that is
absolutely packed with value.
I have Anthony here with me today
a colleague of me at Building
Radar, welcome Anthony
- Good to be here, thanks for having me.
- Awesome and Anthony is
not just any colleague
but he's our Head of Product.
He's actually based in the London office.
We have a second
dependence there in London
and he's visiting this week
here in Munich so I thought
what better opportunity can there be
to just do this together?
Because I think your story
is very, very interesting,
going to dive into that in a moment.
What this episode is going
to be all about is three main points.
First, we are very much
looking to explore the
whole motivation of doing an MBA.
Why should you do an MBA?
Why shouldn't you maybe do an MBA?
So this whole idea of the
reasoning to pursue it
and why you are the
perfect person for that.
Let's talk about this in a moment.
Second, we are also going to
talk about why maybe in the end
of the day, you might
decide not to pursue it.
What other opportunities
are there if you decide
against the MBA and why it
might be a good decision to
then also not do it in the end.
And then last but not least,
we're going to talk about transitioning
from an engineering role to a tech role,
to large tech company at any
of these foreign companies and so on.
Anthony, but maybe just in a nutshell,
why are you the perfect person
to talk about these things about now?
- I guess it was a very funny story.
When you joined the company
I'd only not long been here myself.
Found out that you had
done a MBA at INSEAD.
In fact, the class that
I was supposed to join.
For some of the reasons we'll going today
why I didn't take the INSEAD route.
But yeah hopefully I've got
some interesting insights.
It's a very difficult decision for me.
Maybe you can kind of share that with some
of the views of the channel
that might help inform some
of the hard decisions
they might need to make
about their career development.
- So let's just unpack
the what you said, right?
So Anthony, you applied to INSEAD.
So you did all the things
that are necessary to apply
for an MBA, which is, I
mean quite a lot, right?
So doing an MBA, doing
all the preparation work.
You even told me that did
a C of A level one just
to prep for that.
You applied, you got in, you got the offer
you actually already
accepted the offer right?
You accepted.
- Pay the deposit
- Paid the, how much was that
if you don't mind to share?
- 7,000 euros, is it now.
- 7,000 euros?
So you paid all that and then you decided
in the end not to do it.
But let's dive into that
'cause I think that's very interesting.
Maybe you can share a little bit
just more about your background.
What did you do before all of this
and what was your initial
motivation to pursue it?
Why did you decide that
yes, actually it would
be a great idea for me
personally to do an MBA.
- So I started off, I
studied civil engineering
at university, joined a
structural engineering company.
It's very predictable career path.
You know, could spend
my entire career there.
I was designing skyscrapers.
Moved out to China, more responsibility.
I was quite ambitious
and it started to occur
to me that how did I really
kind of get to the next level?
I started to look at some
of the senior leaders around me, some
of the developer companies
that we were working with
and I started to spot this MBA after many
of their kind of names in the
brushes and things like that.
That was the first time
I really started thinking
about an MBA.
The more I dug into it
the more I kind of reflected
on what I wanted to do
with my own career was
actually move into technology.
I was reading a lot of
stuff in the news, things,
start to wonder, "Hang on a second.
"What if AI starts designing buildings?
"Then what am I going to do?"
Still early in my career.
Had this kind of like
existential threat moment
and figured out that yeah
if somebody was gonna disrupt my industry
then I'd be the one doing it.
And that's kind of what led me to look
at considering an MBA to
make that career transition
into the tech sector.
- You said one thing that
I think is very interesting
and I know that also just in
the Firm Learning community
there's always some debate
also in the comments
if I talk about these things.
You said that you, you know,
you looked at your senior
management, your leadership,
many people had MBAs there.
What is your reflection that
how important is it in a
more traditional company
which I understand that was
your career at that time?
How important is it still to have an MBA?
And to what extent is your perception
that this depends maybe also just
on the region or can just shed
some light that into that?
- Yeah, that's a really good question.
I think in hindsight,
I didn't really understand why
these senior people had MBAs.
It was more like a
pattern that I'd spotted
which kind of led me down, you know
the path of exploring an MBA.
I wouldn't even say
that I knew how an MBA
would get me to that role.
I just felt like it was an
avenue I needed to explore.
And maybe in hindsight, not everybody
in a senior leadership
position has an MBA.
And so there are obviously
other paths to get there.
And I think, yeah, the MBA was
really an opportunity for me
to take some time with
like-minded ambitious individuals
to find out what I actually
really wanted to do
in my career long term.
- And so then this was the journey.
You decided to apply.
Why did you go for INSEAD?
What was appealing for you
for this specific program?
- Yeah, INSEAD, I think one of
the, I mean a big plus point
obviously it's a one year program
and when you're thinking
about opportunity costs.
I was already, you know, into my career.
I guess the second
thing though actually is
that I've since making that
decision lived in America
for a few years
and I've kind of really seen
a different side to America
but maybe as somebody not being born
in America had this kind of, oh, you know
American MBA schools, they're only aware
of American MBA schools and
being a European at heart
I'm gonna go to the European one.
And so INSEAD was high in the ranking
but obviously also being in
Asia at the time, INSEAD having
that Singapore campus was
a really big plus point
for me personally, so.
- So you apply to INSEAD
and, I mean, I think I would
share a similar rationale, right?
So from my humble perspective,
why might INSEAD be a good choice first
if you don't see your future in the U.S.?
Because I think indeed if
you aim to work in the U.S.
the U.S. schools will always
have a better standing
and a better reputation.
I think that's one
important consideration.
Second is that it's a
one year program, right?
So if you think about ROI,
of course the one thing is
that you invest twice the time.
So you have twice the cost in
terms of tuition, living costs
but also you have two years
of forgoing salary, right?
Which I think many people
sometimes forget to include
in the calculation.
So yeah, I might be nice.
And then of course
outside the U.S., I think,
INSEAD may be close to London
Business School and so on,
surely the number one program.
So you applied, you even got in.
Can you just walk us through
this application process?
So what were all the things
that you did for that?
And how did that feel like for you,
someone coming from an
engineering background?
- It was really hard to be quite frank.
And I think actually looking
at one of your recent videos, in fact
you were talking about this kind
of like the danger of over fixating
on a very singular goal.
And I decided I'd internalized
that it was INSEAD
or nothing for various factors.
It's really tough to
get those GMAT scores.
I got something that I
thought might scrape me in.
I spoke to the admissions
officer and she said,
"If you think you can do better,
"you should maybe try again."
And I went and gave another shot.
The, obviously the language, you know
the additional language interview,
that was a big challenge.
But yeah, just thinking back
to those feelings like
waiting for the decision
to come back, wondering whether
my GMAT score was enough.
It really felt at that time
that if I didn't get offered a place
I wouldn't have known
what to have done next.
It would've been, I feel like
such a big disappointment.
I really didn't have a
backup plan at that time.
And in retrospect it was foolish, I think,
to think like that.
- What would you do differently
if you would face the
situation again today?
- I think I needed to, I was
ultimately pursuing an MBA
for a specific outcome and
I knew what the outcome was.
I wanted to get
from the engineering sector
into the tech sector.
And I think I'd just become lost
in the forums and, you
know, the process to think
that an MBA was the only mechanism to get
to where I wanted to go.
And the reality was that
just simply wasn't true
which I later found out.
- Found out that.
And it's interesting,
let's talk about that
in a moment as well.
I mean, you talked about
the GMAT in the beginning.
We quickly talked about this deposit
that you even needed to pay.
I mean, you were really fully committed
and you even joined, I mean,
you showed me some photos
of pre MBA trips, right, that you joined.
I mean, maybe just talk
a little bit about that.
So how did that work?
What did you do there?
- That was fantastic.
So I was living in Shanghai at the time.
I was, I think I was in the
very first cohort accepted.
And so, you know, the
school puts us in touch
with the other people that
were accepted in our cities.
And so lots of great nights
out with all of the
Shanghai INSEAD candidates.
And it was this kind
of like camaraderie that
we were already developing.
We're all so excited for where
we were gonna be next year.
Yeah, it makes me really
actually think about,
that's probably the thing
that makes me really
realize what perhaps I missed out on
by not actually going that route.
But yeah, that was really
kind of fabulous time.
INSEAD were fantastic in terms
of inviting us on campus for like a,
I think it was like a short
weekend where you could kind
of really kind of get a
taste for what it was going
to be like.
I think that really
helped me mentally prepare
for what it was going to be like.
But yeah, in some cases you
are waiting maybe nine months
for the program to start.
That's a really exciting time.
And yeah, it was trying to productively
invest that excitement to
make sure that, you know
I was gonna be as successful
as possible when the program started.
- That sounds great, right.
And you did all that.
You mentally prepared,
you visited the campus,
you joined the pre MBA trips
but still then there was
the point where you said,
"For me at this point in time,
it's not the right decision."
And again, can you unpack this as well?
What led you to that realization?
- Yeah, so it was very much unexpected.
I was, again, I guess,
with all of that energy
getting ready for the program
I really started looking into
applying for internship roles.
Because I didn't have any tech experience
from my careers to date felt
like an internship would really
kind of help me get that first job
after the program finished.
And so I blindly approached
this particular company.
I discovered through the news
which was a Google X
spinout company involved
with automation of design
in the architecture space.
It was, it had my name
written all over it.
I reached out to them once, no response.
Waited a couple months, gave
another shot in the dark
and amazingly somebody got back to me
and that essentially started a series
of interviews with that company.
I did an onsite interview as
well, and surprisingly, I just
I wasn't expecting it, they
offered me a full-time role.
And I was only asking for an internship.
I think startups, they
have a different kind
of timeframe of reference than
maybe the bigger companies.
And they were like, look,
you know, we need you now.
Like, and so, you know, I was saying,
"Well, can I go and do this program first
"and come back in a year?"
And then startup might
not be around in a year
or we might have been doing
something else in a year.
And so I really felt like it
was a now or never opportunity.
And yeah, it was very difficult to think
about all of the things that
I would've missed out on going
to INSEAD, the access to
like a lifetime network,
You know, just the strengthening of my CV.
But at the same time
I already had this option here
to achieve my end objective
which was to transition
into the tech industry.
- Move to San Francisco, move
to the Silicon Valley right.
To really get all this impressions
- Exactly, exactly.
And, you know, obviously,
yeah, there was the 7,000 Euro
down payment and all of
the expectations I'd set
with my friends and my now
wife, that this is what
I was going to do for a year.
But in the end, I think I just
had to be honest with myself
that I was doing the MBA
for this particular outcome.
And here I had a window of opportunity
for this outcome and I had to take it.
- And just for the uninitiated,
I mean, Google X is part
of alphabet, right?
So Google it's this
incubator where they spin
off new innovative businesses
and you had then the
opportunity to join one of them.
So indeed you exactly like
the outcome that you wanted
to get through the MBA
suddenly was presented
to you just like that, just
by you taking the courage
to apply, right.
And I know like why didn't
you apply already before?
I mean, that's the
obvious question, right?
Like, why didn't you
already apply a year earlier
before you even started
applying to the MBA?
- It's a really good question.
There was the reality is
there was nothing stopping me
from doing that.
I think again, in retrospect
I like to think that
doing an MBA is a socially
acceptable reason to totally
change your career trajectory.
And I don't know why, you
know, maybe that fear that
in the future, somebody's going to look
at your CV and there'll
be some career transition
that maybe doesn't make sense.
But yeah, I think the MBA was the thing
that really was just making me reflect.
And as a result gave me the time
and maybe motivation to
think about what I really
wanted to do and then
start taking those actions
I should have just taken earlier.
- Earlier, I think that's fair right.
And at least, and I mean,
you were maybe not lucky.
Probably it is your
abilities and skills, right?
So you were able to get that internship
without the MBA or this position, actually
for many people that
were also in my cohort
or in the cohort that both
of us would've been part of
these types of career
transition surely were one
of the main motivations to do MBAs.
And there were always these three things
that people talked about.
So transitions in regards to geography,
in regards to industry or
in regards to function.
This is what many, many
people were looking after.
So doing a transition, at
least in one of these areas
if not in two or even all
three, and for many, it worked.
For some probably also that
didn't reach the goal post MBA.
And this was, I think indeed also one
of the points I tried to make
in this other video the other week.
I think just not very clever, right.
Just to join, I mean,
just for this one purpose.
I mean you, I think, had
a broader perspective.
It's not that you wanted
to join just this one
specific company, but rather
a sector, an industry.
I think that's probably fair,
but some people are just also
so tied up on some of these other elements
that just doesn't make sense.
But yeah, so it's, I think,
a very bold decision, right,
to just say, "I cut the ties.
"I invested all of this, I did all this
"and I just do, take the other route."
If you reflect on that today,
how do you perceive all
of this that played out now in the end?
I mean, was that the right
decision at the time?
- I guess I'll never know.
I think that's the reality.
I don't have any regrets.
Maybe if I had chosen the
INSEAD path, I don't know.
I don't know how my life
could have been different
but I think it was, again,
the reason why we, you know
so fantastic when you joined the company.
It was like, "Wow, maybe if
I had gone the INSEAD route,
"I would've ended up back
here with Heinrich anyway."
Like maybe these different paths take you
to the same destination.
And yeah, I just think
that that would, again
it was just such a difficult
decision at the time.
I really wasn't sure which route was going
to have the highest payoff
long term in my career.
I think that I went for
the short term opportunity
versus the long term gains
that you almost guaranteed get
with that MBA program
and the brand recognition
and the access to the community.
But again, it was a means to an end
and there seemed like there was a shortcut
to the end that
I had to take.
- That makes sense.
Let's maybe as a third
part of this video talk
about just in general, this transition
from engineering to tech.
Because I mean, again
just also reading comments
and listening to many
of you guys out there.
I know that many
of you also come from
a technical background.
So rather than sense of
engineering than the tech industry
and actually would love
to do this transition.
Do you have any advice or
maybe also just reflections
on your journey to share
what people can do?
So an MBA can be an option.
I think this is one of the learnings
but doesn't need to be an option.
So what is your take on this,
on succeeding in this transition?
- I think the reality is
that the tech sector didn't exist maybe 15
20 years ago in the form
that it exists today.
And so it wasn't like
there were a million people
all studying tech at university
and now they all work in the tech sector.
They came from other programs like finance
or traditional engineering programs
but also creative functions as well.
And so, yeah, I think I had it in my head
that I had have studied
software engineering
and that it was too late already.
And therefore I could
never get a seat, you know
in the tech sector.
But yeah, actually I'm really astonished
at the the variety of backgrounds
that people have coming
into the tech sector.
And also the realization
that not everybody at a tech
company writes software.
There's people like yourself
involved with, you know
how do we market and sell
the product, what I do now.
Like how do we decide what to even build?
I think coming
from an engineering
background is a big plus point
in the tech sector, because
at the end of the day
you are working with software engineers
and having that engineering background
being able to empathize
with the realities of building anything
put me in a relatively strong position
but also like the rise
of B2B software companies
having a specific industry background
and bringing that knowledge
of the construction sector
which I had
into a tech company helped
us build new tech products
for the construction sector.
And so yeah
in a way it can actually be
a golden ticket to get in.
- And actually, if you would be interested
to join a tech company as well,
we here at Building Radar,
we are currently hiring.
There's several open positions.
We will leave job posting links
to that in the description.
So feel free to check it out.
Both actually for your team
and also for our business team here.
There's one key hire at the
moment that we're looking
for that we are calling
a revenue engineer.
And no worries this does nothing have
to do with engineering.
So you don't need to be an engineer.
It's more con consulting business type
of role where we work together closely.
First of all, with us as
a senior leadership here
at Building Radar, but also with some
of our most senior clients,
most important clients.
And you would have a key part
in really shaping the direction
of our company with that.
So if you would be interested
we would love to get your
applications for that.
Just two requirements specifically
for the revenue engineer role.
You would need to be based in Munich
and you would need to
be able to speak German.
Anthony, big, big, thanks
for this little conversation we had.
Also I just learned a couple of new points
that also didn't knew
about you, which was,
I think quite fantastic.
Appreciate your time.
Thank you so much.
And let's see, I think we have lots
of other topics to potentially
explore in the future.
Maybe also about what it's like
to be a Chief Product
Officer or things like that.
So let's see if there's maybe
episode two with Anthony.
Maybe also let us know the comments
if you would be interested in that.
Thank you.
As always if you took any
value out of this video
smash the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and subscribe to stay up
to date on all the content.
Big, big, thanks all the
members Firm Learning
for your support.
Very much appreciate it.
My name is Heinrich.
I release weekly videos
here on the channel.
Next one you will see next Saturday.
So until then all the best to you all.
And bye bye, thank you.